so time magazine's latest issue echoes
the hyperbole found all over
social media by dubbing 2020 quote the
worst year ever
i think most of the people who say this
don't mean it literally i hope
anyway they don't mean it literally 2020
obviously is not the worst year ever i
mean any of the years in the late 14th
century
when the black plague was in the process
of wiping out half of europe's
population
were probably quite a bit worse than
this one or say 1862 when over
20 000 people were killed in one day in
just
one battle of the civil war that was
antietam uh that year was i'm guessing
much more challenging than this one the
same goes for 1861 1863 1864 or any of
the years leading up to and preceding
the civil war
in fact i bet if you were transported to
any year
prior to our modern age anywhere on
earth
you would within hours be begging for
the comfort and tranquility of america
circa the year of our lord 2020.
i'm not sure what exactly was happening
in say
1648 or 1234 or 1705 but i do know that
the nights were cold
survival was hard people probably didn't
smell very good
your children not all of them probably
would live to adulthood
and you would probably be dead before
50. so no
2020 is not the worst year ever not even
close to it and it's important to
establish that fact because
if we lose our sense of perspective then
we will not be able to rationally
evaluate our situation and make good and
coherent choices in fact
it is this lack of perspective this
inability to rationally evaluate
that has contributed greatly towards
making 2020 if not the worst year ever
at least a bad year and perhaps the
worst in several decades
it's what has scared people into
submitting to tyranny from the
government
and as far as that goes i think we can
say without melodrama or hyperbole that
what the government has done over the
past several months
has been oppressive tyrannical and
capricious
to an extent unprecedented in our
lifetimes at least
this may not be the worst year literally
in history
but some of what has happened we have
never seen before
and it is very terrible indeed on that
end here's the latest the report from
cnn reporting
some real and important news for a
change i don't know if their normal
editors are on vacation or what to let
this slip through but
here's what the article says it says
about 17 of america's restaurants
have already permanently closed this
year with thousands more on the brink
according to a new report the national
restaurant association is publicly
pleading with congress to pass new
stimulus to help the industry
that has been damaged by the pandemic
the group said monday that 10 000
restaurants could close in the next
three weeks
in addition to the 110 000 that have
already shuttered in 2020.
now just to stop for a moment here uh to
really
think about this because you become numb
to these numbers after a while
110 000 restaurants have closed this
year 110
000. if i had told you in december of
2019
that in the following year over a
hundred thousand restaurants would be
closed
first of all you wouldn't believe me
second if you did believe me you would
think that i was describing
some kind of sudden economic apocalypse
some sort of act of god coming out of
the sky out of the blue to destroy an
entire industry in one fell swoop
and you would be wrong in that
assumption this has been an intentional
deliberate targeted act decision
by our elected leaders now a little bit
more from cnn it says
the group released results from a survey
of 6 000 restaurant operators revealing
that 87
of full-service restaurants reported an
average 36 percent drop in revenue
and 83 expect sales to be even worse
over the next three months as the virus
continues to lash the united states
sean kennedy executive vice president of
the group said in short the restaurant
industry simply cannot wait for relief
any longer
he advocates for a true compromise
between the competing democrat
and republican proposals and hopes for a
larger stimulus package in 2021 under
the incoming by the administration cnn
businesses dashboard tracking america's
recovery
shows a steep drop in restaurant
reservations down 70
during the pandemic they recovered in
september
have fallen once again a bipartisan
stimulus proposal could be unveiled this
week it's unclear if the extension of
the paycheck protection program
which the group wants will be included
now i said that cnn was reporting real
news for a change but
they can't help themselves of course as
usual the media reports that
even acknowledge the devastation will
always blame
lay the blame on the virus they lay the
blame of the economic
devastation on the virus well the virus
and donald trump
notice it says that the situation with
restaurants will get even worse
as the virus continues to lash the
united states
but it's not the virus doing this the
virus hasn't closed one single
restaurant
our response to the virus has done that
the distinction really matters because
it's not as though this was unavoidable
it's not as though a virus
had to demolish the restaurant industry
and put hundreds of thousands of people
just from that industry alone out of
work there were
other ways of responding but we and by
we i mean they the politicians the
bureaucrats
chose this way they did this not the
virus
economically anyway they are the ones
lashing the united states not the virus
virus and now we're told that the only
solution
is to rely on the people who cause the
problem to begin with
we have to beg them to hammer out a deal
and pass a stimulus
that's the solution which yes they do
need to hammer out a deal and pass a
stimulus if they're gonna put
millions of people out of work and shut
down millions of businesses it's their
responsibility to offer
some kind of compensation but this is a
band-aid at best
not a solution it's not what will save
the restaurant industry or any other
industry from full collapse
it's not what will save our economy or
reclaim our country or win back the
rights we've forfeited
the only way to really reclaim what has
been taken
is simply to take it back not to ask for
it to be given back but to take it
business owners should just open their
businesses
no matter what the restrictions and
ordinances say no matter what
gavin newsom or andrew cuomo thinks
about it
flip on the open side unlock the door
start doing business again
churches should open their doors invite
their congregations in
not waiting for permission from the
mayor or the sheriff or even their
bishop
if we're talking about a catholic church
people who want to
walk down the street without a mask
should simply walk down the street
without a mask
this is how america became a free
country in the first place
if you're waiting for the government to
give you permission to be free
you've already lost the only way is to
say
i am free i am an american
and this is what i'm going to do try and
stop me
and maybe they will try and stop you
maybe they won't if enough people join
you
they won't be able to stop you if people
don't join you
then even so at least you can know that
you did the right thing
the american thing you didn't take the
tyranny lying down
you chose at least to be free well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
walsh show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content